I want to start today with an explosive
confrontation that took place during
another one of these Republican Senate
hearings this particular confrontation
involved unhinged Republican senator
Mark Wayne Mullen uh as well or with or
alongside or up against I guess you
would say Teamsters president Sean
O'Brien Teamsters of course a union
Republicans tend not to like unions
Republicans love to frame unions as sort
of like mob entities and the guys or
gals who run unions as as mob bosses and
we've seen that narrative for a while
the big Continuing Story since
Republicans have taken over control of
the house is the humiliating face
planting and self-destructive nature of
these hearings the hearings that
Republicans have organized and this is
happening in the house and the Senate uh
on big and and crossover hearings as
well
um on big Tech on weaponization of the
justice system or whatever the case may
be and even when it is not Republicans
who organize the hearing they still find
new ways to humiliate themselves so
let's take a look at this video Bernie
Sanders was sort of trying to uh
officiate this thing and it is the
latest Brazen attempt uh by Republicans
to attack labor which is what they love
to do you talk about CEO those that are
making all this money
and what do you make Mr O'Brien well I'm
glad you asked that question yeah I know
what you make because in 2019 your
salary was
um what is this 193 000 I'm sure you've
got some pay raises since then yeah
so basically like the same salary as
Mark Wayne Mullen gets as a senator
that's an interesting thing a little
higher PS driver the feeder driver makes
35 000 a year and what do you bring
that's inaccurate hold on a second
that's inaccurate right here stay faxed
that's an act average UPS feeder driver
makes 35 000 if you don't know your
facts and maybe use I know because I
negotiate so I say I say one thing to
you what do you bring for that salary
what do I bring yeah what do you what
job have you committed or have you have
you uh uh started what job have you
created one job other than sucking a
paycheck
out of some other by somebody else that
you want to say that you're trying to
provide because you're forced so
remember the narrative here is
unions are oppressive the people who run
them take money in exchange for nothing
other than forcing the workers to pay
union dues and we would all be better
off if there were no unions and the
workers had a direct relationship with
the companies now of course we know that
that's not the case and we know that as
a result of the unions and being able to
collectively bargain in this way the
workers actually end up earning more on
average all else being equal but that's
not the story that Republicans like to
tell about unions
don't tell me I'm out of
linear statement because you don't know
yes I did what yeah older tough guy
but don't sit there and tell me I'm out
of line
set it up
he made a statement you asked the
question I didn't ask a question you did
it I did a question you asked the
question
let him answer Israel you may think it's
rhetorical it founded to be like a
question let him answer the question I'm
not yielding my time to him so if you're
going to let me keep my time that's fine
you'll have your time let him you ask a
question he has no right to answer that
as far as my salary goes my salary if
you follow me around I walk I actually
look at this building I bet you I work
more hours than you do twice as many
hours that's impossible but no that is
that's true sir
greedy CEOs like yourself accountable
you call me a greedy oh yeah you are you
want to attack my salary I'll Attack
y'all what do I make what did you make
when you owned your company well I made
my company I kept my salary down at
about 50 000 a year because I'm better
now this we all know this game this is
so just I kept my salary down and of
course as CEO Mark Wayne Mullen made
tens of millions of dollars towards his
net worth from non-salary compensation
typical move maybe he thinks nobody else
knows that but we know that game said
every penny into it okay all right you
mean you hid money no I didn't oh oh
hold on a second okay so there's a
couple different things here that I
think are important to mention
um one of those things is the general
idea that Republicans want to put out
there and I don't even want to say that
Republicans believe they may not believe
it as we know a lot of this stuff is
just performance the idea that they put
out there
is that rather than a tool or an
infrastructure that allows workers to
organize and to pool their negotiating
strength in order to obtain better
salary and benefits from a situation in
which an individual worker has
disproportionately little power right
that's essentially what the union allows
workers to do in order to get higher
salary and better benefits the union
they frame as almost like a leech that
just collects dues forcibly which by the
way often is not the case that you're
forced into the Union into pay dues in
fact sometimes it's the opposite where
even if you refuse to pay the dues the
union still represents you but that's a
detail and depends on the union and it
takes away value the idea is oh the
workers come out with less because not
only do they end up having to uh pay the
dues they don't even get a higher salary
or better benefits we know that that's
not the case I mean it's been studied
endlessly and we know that's not the
case so that's that's number one and
then number two with all of these
Republicans some personal hypocrisy is
not far behind and it is not lost on me
and I hope it's not lost on you the
irony or the absurdity
of Mark Wayne Mullen calling the
Teamsters president with a low
six-figure salary the greedy CEO when
the entire point of the teamsters is to
negotiate better pay and benefits for
for tons of different workers when Mark
Wayne mullen's net worth and his assets
exploded by tens of millions of dollars
tens of millions of dollars over the
last few years so they are pathetic yes
they are hypocrites yes but they also
have to lie about unions now I am not an
unreasonable person when it comes to
unions I recognize that there are lots
of small businesses where a union
doesn't really make sense and I am not
someone who goes around and says every
business should be unionized that's just
not my view I've not come to believe
that that's the best thing but when
you're talking about these organizations
with tons of workers electricians
electricians union trade unions for
particular companies UPS Etc
the Dynamics of those companies and the
sheer scale of those companies are such
that there has to be some mechanism for
all of these employees who have shared
interests to be able to pool their power
because remember when there are thirty
thousand sixty thousand employees or
whatever the case may be one person if
forced to negotiate individually has
relatively little power because they can
just be excluded or pushed to the side
or their their influence minimized when
the negotiation is happening
collectively that is a very different
situation and it puts large companies in
the position
of having to really come to the table
not necessarily in good faith but at
least willing to negotiate in a real way
so very interesting exchange and shows
the continued hostility towards labor
from the modern Republican Party